[Music]
where do you go to quench your thirst
the kitchen sink the local bar the
mineral-rich springs of bergamo italy in
the 21st century you don't have to go
that far for fresh water but still
supply is running out what if we didn't
have to worry about water consumption
what if you could drink and shower as
much as you wanted what if a trip to the
well and a trip to the beach we're one
in the same you might give a lot for
those privileges but how much would it
really cost this is what if and here's
what would happen if all sea water
became freshwater the first big question
we have to ask is why is the ocean so
salty to begin with well it wasn't
always like that
about 3.8 billion years ago Earth's
surface had finally cooled to the point
that water vapour turned to liquid no
salt added that's right a really really
long time ago the oceans were freshwater
but that wasn't going to last whenever
it rains carbon dioxide from the air
dissolves into the falling water this
makes the rain slightly acidic and when
it falls it causes rocks to erode from
there
rainwater slides towards nearby rivers
and streams taking loose salt and
minerals along with it from there this
runoff flows from rivers into the ocean
add to that any additional salt and
minerals that would be expelled from
hydrothermal vents or submarine
volcanoes and then consider that this
whole process has been recurring more or
less consistently for 3.8 billion years
that's a lot of salt in fact there's so
much salt in the ocean that if you
spread it evenly across all the land on
earth it would amount to one towering
layer of salt that's 40 stories tall 97%
of all the water on Earth is saline and
we've got to assume it's for a reason so
what would our world look like if we
took the salt out of the sea fresh water
oceans sure do sound like a godsend
right now it's predicted that a third of
the world will be facing chronic water
shortages by 2025
at our current rate of consumption the
global demand for fresh water doubles
every 20 years
so maybe fresh water oceans would
actually yield a good outcome this time
nope a sea without salt would decimate
marine life and dramatically affect our
weather and temperatures making human
life on Earth very difficult if not
impossible there are roughly two hundred
and twenty eight thousand four hundred
and fifty species in the ocean and as
many as two million more to be
discovered but if the ocean were to
become desalinated we'd never find them
saltwater fish and other ocean creatures
evolved to be able to drink salt water
to stay hydrated and get rid of excess
salt not all sea creatures do this the
same way but being able to pump out
excess salt is crucial to surviving in
the ocean some species like salmon have
adapted to tolerate freshwater and
saltwater but for the most part all
saltwater species would perish this
includes underwater algae which believe
it or not accounts for half the
photosynthesis that occurs on earth
photosynthesis plays a vital role in
supplying our planet with oxygen since
trees and plants convert carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere into the air we
breathe
so without algae not only do we get less
oxygen we also have a lot more carbon
dioxide in our atmosphere this
intensification of the greenhouse effect
would make some parts of the world
unbearably hot you definitely notice
this intense heat near the equator
since our ocean currents wouldn't be
circulating warm water and air the way
they used to convection currents help
warm water from the equator get farther
north while colder water from the north
is able to cool hotter areas down south
at the equator warmer water can carry
more salt
so this denser water sinks lower while
cooler water flows over top of it and in
the far north the water gets cold enough
to freeze and form sea ice salt gets
left behind as the water freezes and
naturally this makes colder water up
north denser allowing it to sink to the
bottom to make room for the incoming
warmer water that's worked its way up
from the south but without salt the
whole process breaks down Earth's
extremities would freeze while weather
around the equator would intensify for
one thing hurricanes would be a lot more
frequent and a lot more deadly
at this point our weather and our
climate would be totally different from
how we know it now how long would we
survive to see all these changes not
long at all you'd either freeze over
heat die in a natural disaster or starve
to death
yeah with significantly less
photosynthesis and climates that are
either extremely cold or extremely hot
our weather would no longer support the
diverse plant life that has now the
entire food chain would collapse
most species would die off including
humans since crops we rely on for
sustenance would all disappear so when
we say ocean salinization is important
don't take it with a grain of salt
of course we respect the scientific
method so keep questioning the world and
its properties on land and beyond and
come back soon for another what-if
[Music]